this part of the world owes its history
to coal nobody goes down the pits
anymore and in blaine that's taken its
toll but they can feel the climate is
changing
do you think that places like this would
have an uncomfortable relationship with
climate change um to some people yeah
the heritage of this town is the coal
and the iron works
and without that there wouldn't be a
town
a poll for sky news suggests
increasingly there's a reckoning over
global warming 76 percent of people we
spoke to accept the climate is changing
due to human activity but almost
two-thirds said they haven't been paying
attention to the climate change
conference
ten-year-old mason is amongst those who
have been following events
what do you know about cop26 it's doing
it in glasgow and stuff and people are
marching around and all
but blaine avon is altogether less
frenetic and that's part of the problem
back in the day this would have been a
gold rush town now businesses have
closed poverty levels are high and
people are worried about the cost of
living let alone saving the planet
locals admit the electric car bays
aren't used much
signmaker yazia says he's struggling to
find labour to keep his businesses going
from a business point of view
it's all about affordability whether you
can afford to change your vehicles etc
etc
our survey suggests people are split on
whether taxes should be increased to
help pay the costs of reducing carbon
emissions in britain 44 per cent oppose
the idea
obviously with it being milder better
grass
growth
sheep farmer james bourne knows better
than most how the seasons have changed
in some respects it's already too late
i think
that you know in time the world
probably will come together to to make
it to improve things
but i don't think it's something that's
going to happen
you know in the short term
in the darkness
of the
minds where you age
before your time
one thing that's not changed is blind
evan's choir still going after more than
a hundred years
farmer james is a baritone and took us
to meet some other members and their
friends to discuss how habits in the
hillsides are changing
i think that's
in a town like this which is typical of
many towns in britain there's a way we
would put heat pumps on these
on these terraced houses now we've got
food banks and all these towns we've
gone backwards and i think most people
are worried about that and climate
change
in our survey more than two-thirds said
they felt pessimistic that the world
will make the changes necessary to limit
the impact of climate change
i think there's a lot of passion but i
do worry how much of it actually can get
done
i never the planet needs more than
prayers
and as our poll suggests a greater
global willingness for one community to
save another
lisa holland sky news blind